[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to behind the screens the
show where we talk about movie news
reviews and interviews hey I'm your host
ashcroft and I have a lot for you this
week between shazam Annabel creation and
Beck Bennett is here to talk about duck
tales but first let's go to the news of
the week
director David F Sandburg is following
that James Wan path going from the
conjuring verse to the DC extended
universe he's taking on Shazam which too
many will be the introduction of a brand
new superhero I know it is for me so I
asked him all about this at the
Annabelle premiere how would you
describe the tone of Sharia it's a very
fun movie like a fun light-hearted movie
you know because it's about a kid who
gets to become an adult superhero so I
mean that's just with me so fun to
explore is this going to be I'm assuming
we're going full origin story I mean
what is your perception of introducing
the world to a superhero that a lot of P
I mean for a lot of people this will be
the introduction to Suzanne I mean to be
honest it was not a super ear I grew up
with either because he was not when I
grew up in Sweden it wasn't a lot of
Shazam around so someone who I've
learned to love later in life as well
so I can relate to that so being new to
sis at which is I think might be a good
thing that I'm doing it because you know
I know what you need to learn he also
seemed to know who the cast is but
wouldn't tell me so it's possible we're
getting that news very soon but first
his movie Annabelle creation is hitting
theaters August 11th which brings us to
this week's movie ticket
Annabelle creation is the sequel to
Annabelle and a spin-off of the
conjuring movies which is now becoming
its own expansive universe the movie is
the origin story of that creepy
Annabelle doll who was living among six
orphan girls imagine acting with this
thing her eyes are the creepiest part I
feel like because like I said before
they follow you around and around no
matter if you're trying to hide or to
try to turn her head away she just keeps
staring who's artists for their kid
she's I know right that's exactly what I
was saying
it was just scary because how can you
not be scared of her like her eyes and
her face expression everything about her
so that was definitely little pieces to
this freak about having that dawn son
know I have it at home now she lives in
our guest room really yeah it's actually
true that's why we don't have guests
okay well not everyone was creeped out
by her definitely go check it out if you
want to get spooked in theaters but if
you're looking for a laughs and staying
at home you can solve a mystery or
rewrite history with the ducktales
revival and I have a special guest here
to talk about it let's go to our
interview spotlight hey everyone Beck
Bennett is one of several comedic voices
coming to the new duck tales revival
it's coming in September but first there
is a TV movie happening this weekend
August 12th Launchpad McQuack himself
here is really out here thank you for
having me thank you for being daring
great to be here yes not only as duck
tales being revived its coinciding with
a 30th anniversary of the show which I
did not know I didn't either new to you
no idea yeah no it's perfect timing were
you a big duck tail stand back in the
day I was a huge fan back in the day
yeah it was like for me it was like
looking back on and remembering it it's
like the sort of like the theme song was
like the snacks Bell to me instead of
like the dinner bell they like get home
from school like turn it on my snack and
like watch the Disney Afternoon or
whatever else before I go do my homework
hey that was mine too yeah I don't
remember it being maybe a lot of those
jokes went over my head when I was a
kids I don't remember being as funny as
it is now is so good I think it was I
mean it was fun and there were like a
lot of great jokes and sweets but I
think was more for kids I think a lot of
cartoons are more for kids then now it's
like it's this really fun thing where
it's like material for grownups and
their kids to watch together from and I
think that's what that's like one of the
main differences with the new duck tales
is that like it's for the people who
grew up watching duck tales and are now
like in their 30s or whatever and and
have kids and their watches with their
kids yeah so I could be like hey let's
let let's bond let's bond let's watch
duck tail time together now family is
adventurers
and as humans over these family of
adventuring ducks we could solve a
mystery we could rewrite this yes yes
yeah did you come over yeah that's
amazing yeah oh yeah basically the show
that's great fantastic don't know where
I came up Abed
well Launchpad McQuack is the pilot but
maybe that's obsessed no he's the best
in Duxbury and Duckburg is known for
having some of the best pilots and
chauffeurs I Drive anything up that can
be driven pretty much I would say with
with wings or wheels but pretty much
anything like submarines for example
really anything well his skill is that
he crashes things so just some people
that may not be a good thing but for
launchpad it is very proud of his
crashing and he always walks away from
it unscathed and nobody's ever really
hurt right crash except for like other
physical things but no people oh good I
don't want to feel like Huey was like an
arm hanging just random that'll never
happen
he's incredibly talented he always walks
away from a crash very proud about well
like we were talking about earlier like
great great great voice actors coming
onto this show is there anyone that
you're working with now that you've
never worked with before and we're very
excited to work with yes Danny Pudi Ben
Schwartz and Kate Micucci are all other
comedic performers that I really respect
and I met Kate before and I never met
Danny or Ben so they were kind of like
in my world and people that I liked
really respected obviously David Tennant
as well but those three are like sort of
peers of mine a little bit older so I
was like really honored to be a part of
this series with them yeah
you guys record together we don't know
so I've been recording because I'm in
New York and Los Angeles and I go back
and forth maybe sometimes Danny and Ben
do or maybe Kate as well but you know I
recorded in New York like while I'm
shooting SNL or wherever I am and so
I've been for the past year and a half
of the recording launchpad by myself in
a room sometimes like via Skype with the
creators and the writers so yeah it was
like a really interesting way to get
into
TV show yeah I grew up watching it was
like I'd see people on a computer like
hey how's it going we like met each
other through Skype and I did it you
know happy with it is that is that
different for you though because you're
such you have like this improv
background where you're kind of bouncing
off of each other and now you're doing
it solo yeah yeah I mean it's I mean
like it's kind of similar because you're
just like you're doing a character
you're doing a voice and you can
improvise and in a way it's like you
just get to go off by yourself and you
know it's kind of say whatever you want
and you like do it again and say
whatever you want but I mean you all so
very much stick to their brilliant
script the favorite and make that work
but um but yeah it's like I said it's
totally different you like you don't get
to see the material all I haven't seen
any of them I've seen little bits and
pieces but so you kind of go like what
does it look like what is it you know
yeah
it's beautiful the animation is awesome
so beautiful yeah yeah and lastly I want
to bring up frisky bear because last
time we talked
audiences hasn't seen it yet but now
that people have and it's being so
well-received and yeah what does that
mean to to you and to Kyle it's a date
it's uh just makes me so happy
really I mean it's um you know we've
been working together for 14 years I met
in college and we were like making short
videos since we were 18 and then so to
have this movie connect independently of
like sketch comedy and like you because
we did good neighbor and that found an
audience and good neighbor went into FNL
but it wasn't kind of through SNL we
were you know part of that huge
institution right she we were part of
that it wasn't like totally independent
you know so to be a part of this movie
it's really you know Kyle's baby
um and stabbed a direct and for meeting
Nick to have parts in it is really sweet
because it's also about finding your
friends they're sort of similar creative
bond with your family and stuff like
that so in a way it's kind of like
resonating what a good neighbor went
through and how we found each other and
how we you know grew together in like a
crazy quirky way yeah that's it for this
week's behind the screens make sure to
check out ETS YouTube page there's new
shows every single day something for
everyone and I will see you guys next
week
you